efféminé
tb
télé
tt
[Musique]
télé
à 7,8 en jette un petit monstre qui
savait tournée et mon père
m'emmenait dont les foi entrent limay
où il me
mettait devant un tour à tour eu
quasiment préhistorique où se tourne
elle devant des
masses de public j'étais une sorte de
phénomène de fois
non
[Musique]
e
j'ai commencé à faire des poteries
géantes des poutres hitchcock toral
avec cette fameuse terre de de base et
non gélives et puis et puis je me suis
dit que c'était peut-être mieux de
revenir au bercail
réaliser des poteries usuelles et là il
ya eu
un autre miracle
c'est cette poterie c'est bondues dans
tout car trop c'est dans toute l'europe
jusque dans les années 2000
et j'ai commencé à ce moment-là à
m'intéresser encore plus à la sculpture
et au bronze
mon projet en
1986 dont j'ai fait l'acquisition du
château était de le sauver
dès que je les achetais j'ai entrepris
des travaux
herculéens vraiment herculéen c'était
compliqué
afin de le mettre hors d'eau j'ai
évidemment compris que c'était un lieu
d'accueil
une possibilité
presque miraculeuse pour mettre des ce
que tu en voilà
[Musique]
il ya une centaine de sculptures
monumentales
voilà
[Musique]
c'est un crapauds grenouilles à
batraciens qui symbolise
la violence de l'homme sur l'animal
c'est le mal triomphe en texan dont son
excellence je ne suis pas tendre avec ce
genre d'homme
je célèbre plus la femme que loeb non
mes sculptures
c'est la dernière sculpture en acier
inoxydable
en fait elle est emblématique des temps
présents dont la mesure où on ne parle
que de ça cette
seringue et triomphal
c'est un monument à la gloire d'un objet
ordinaire très ordinaire qui devient
extraordinaire
[Musique]